This video is brought to you by keeps
[inaudible].
The wisecrack Jared here coming from these self isolating comforts of my own
apartment. And let me tell you, I got a bad feeling about this. No,
I'm not just talking about my dwindling supplies of top ramen and coffee,
but well, this.
I have a bad feeling about this. I got a bad feeling about this.
I got a bad feeling about this. I've got a bad feeling about it.
Yes.
The time has finally come to delve into the least controversial subject on the
internet,
Little yarn called star Wars.
When the rise of Skywalker was set for release director,
JJ Abrams promised this final entry in the saga would tie up everything that had
come before per the filmmaker.
This wasn't just the end of a single movie or even a trilogy.
It was the end of an entire nine films saga.
It had to be the end of not just three movies, but nine movies.
The question of course,
could the rise of Skywalker possibly tie up every loose end in story thread in a
satisfying way. I mean, this is a gargantuan seemingly impossible task,
and yet somehow they did it after the film's release.
The rise of Skywalker was lauded as the best star Wars film of all time.
And the internet came together in universal celebration. Oh wait,
sorry. I was imagining an alternate timeline.
We're going out to the grocery store. Isn't an episode of black mirror. No,
the rise of Skywalker was of course a colossal disappointment filled with
awkward exposition plot holes and strange red conning of its predecessors.
So what the hell happened? How did the rise of Skywalker fails? So, absolutely.
Well the answer lies in the past. You know, that thing,
the last film kinda sorta tried to kill.
Sorry, kill it. If you have to.
So welcome to this wisecrack edition on the rise of Skywalker,
what went wrong and of course, spoilers ahead for the whole Skywalker saga.
But before we get into it,
I want to give a shout out to this week's sponsor keeps it can be hard to admit
that you're losing your hair, especially when in my case,
it's pretty intertwined with my identity. It's tough to talk about,
but ignoring it won't solve. The problem with hair loss prevention is key.
Two out of three guys will experience some form of male pattern baldness by the
time they're 35. And although I'm praying,
I'm the one out of three it's best to be sure keeps is an affordable hair loss
treatment plan that brings FDA approved prescription and over-the-counter
medication right to your door. Their treatments can combat hair loss.
So you keep the hair on your head with keeps some men even experienced hair
regrowth. You can meet with the keeps doctor,
right from the comfort of your own home. From there,
you can order your treatments and keep track of your progress.
Find out why keeps has more five-star reviews than any of its competitors.
And widen nearly 100,000 men.
Trust keeps for their hair loss prevention medication by clicking the link in
the description, or by going to keep stock com slash wisecrack.
If you use our link, you can get 50% off your first order.
So stop stressing about your hair. And now back to the, all right,
let's get into a quick recap. The rise of Skywalker begins with the resistance,
intercepting a message that Palpatine is somehow not only alive and well,
but amassing a fleet of ships on the hidden planet, exit goal, our heroes, Ray,
Finn,
and Poe go in search of a Wayfinder that will lead to the mysterious planet.
Meanwhile,
Kylo Ren at the behest of Palpatine is tasked with killing Ray and ending the
Jedi once. And for all, from there,
you get your typical light saber duels chases rescue missions and cameos by
beloved characters.
There's even some new character revelations and backstories Kylo basically tells
Ray not to pay attention to anything that happened in the last Jedi.
They're filthy jump traders. So to offer drinking money
in a pauper's grave in the jacuzzi desert.
Instead it turns out Ray, isn't a nobody, but actually.
Don't trust have power. You have his power.
Don't want his granddaughter.
This is followed by some more lightsaber duels chases and rescue missions
interspersed with a classic character heroically sacrificing themselves,
the film culminates in an aerial battle between the resistance and the first
order while Ray faces off against Palpatine with the help of bad guy gone light
Kylo, Ren Ray kills Palpatine, but in doing so dies, of course,
10 seconds later, Kylo brings her back to life,
sacrificing himself in the process.
We end with Ray taking up the mantle of the sky.
Walkers, who are you? I'm Ray,
Ray ho.
If all this sounds very familiar,
like you've seen this same story play out before. Well that's because you have,
oddly enough,
George Lucas spells it out in a behind the scenes featurette on the making of
the Phantom menace.
Lucas explains how anagen is directly modeled after Luke Skywalker.
You see the echo of where it all is going to go.
And instead of destroying the death star,
he destroys the ship that controls the robots. Again, it's like poetry.
So if they run.
For Lucas,
the story of star Wars was all about how history is constantly repeating itself.
There are hundreds of echoes in the prequels directly correlating to the
original trilogy.
A young Anacon blows up the control ship just as Luke will blow up the death
star.
Both guys lose a hand and a lightsaber duel obiwan watches helplessly as his
mentor.
QuakeCon gin is killed by Darth Maul mirroring obiwan his own eventual demise
with Luke helplessly, watching from the sidelines.
And it isn't just these plot elements that bridge the two series together.
Even the visual language of the prequels directly mirrors the original trilogy
to quote another scifi. Epic.
It's happened before. And all of that will happen again.
There's one person who took Lucas's approach to heart JJ Abrams in an interview
for the force awakens Abraham stress. The importance of repetition.
Part of the story of this movie is history repeats itself,
but Abrams took Lucas's approach one step further getting super meta to the
filmmaker. It wasn't just history that was repeating, but the actual themselves,
I wanted to tell a story that was not just history repeating itself,
but a story that embraced the movies that we know as the actual history of this
galaxy, this is not about a nostalgia play. It felt to me like a way of saying,
let's go back to a star Wars that we know so we can tell another story for
Abrams.
The fact that the force awakens is pretty much a carbon copy of a new hope is in
and of itself. The point for a pop culture, savant like Abrams.
It's not enough to merely echo the events that came before.
Instead he has to repeat them and copy the previous trilogy wholesale,
thus raise a stand-in for Luke Kylo for Darth Vader PO for Han solo.
Even the basic story is the same a group of rebels fight against the nefarious
imperialist army hell.
There's even a droid with an important message that can turn the tides of the
war. Now, Lucas and Abrams.
Aren't the first people to claim that history has a tendency to repeat itself.
This notion dates all the way back to the dialectic bad boy himself,
gay Yorkville home Hagle in haggles lectures on the philosophy of history.
The philosopher famously stated that revolutionary acts always tend to occur
twice per Hagle in all periods of the world.
A political revolution is sanctioned in men's opinions when it repeats itself by
repetition,
that which at first appeared in merely a matter of chance and contingency
becomes a real and ratified existence.
As proof Hagle cited the formation of the Roman empire Caesar Caesar first led a
revolution to take over Rome and the Republic and become its defacto emperor.
Many objected to Caesar's reign though,
leading to a second revolution in which he was assassinated,
but in the aftermath,
this second revolution only reinforced the idea that one single emperor was
needed to rule in effect cementing Caesar's initial revolution to destroy the
Republic. In a nutshell,
the revolution has to happen a second time to make the first one work.
The latest trilogy of star Wars films adopts this same philosophy in the
original trilogy, the rebels defeat emperor Palpatine and the empire.
But this revolution is short-lived in the ashes of the empires defeat.
The first order rises to power,
thereby prompting a second revolution in the rise of Skywalker, Ray, Finn,
and Poe lead. The second rebellion to victory.
Finally cementing the rebels victory that came before.
It's pretty much exactly as Hegel himself described the revolution repeating
twice in order to fully take effect yet in channeling,
the spirit of Hagle Abrams has fallen into a kind of historical trap set forth
as an addendum to Hegel's philosophy in 1852 philosopher,
Karl Marx stated that history doesn't quite repeat itself.
Instead it parodies itself. As he writes, Hagle stated that all great world,
historic facts and percentages appear. So to speak twice.
He forgot to add the first time as tragedy.
The second time as farce for marks, when a revolution repeats itself,
it's not the cement that reinforces the original,
but is instead a mockery of what came before.
Mark's most famously applied this criticism to Louis Bonaparte,
the nephew of Napoleon who much like his uncle led a rebellion to seize France
and become emperor.
Louis even led his COO on the anniversary of his uncle's coronation as the
emperor of France yet for Marx,
Louie was nothing but a character of the old Napoleon dressing up like his
famous uncle repeating his same populous rhetoric,
but betraying Napoleon's own principles for marks little Louis duplicates,
the cult of Napoleon in order to legitimize himself.
But without the values of his uncle,
he became nothing more than a hollow parody. History had repeated,
but merely as a farce of the original, just like Napoleon 2.0,
dressed up as his legendary uncle without understanding what made him a
competent leader rise of Skywalker dresses itself in the nostalgia of star Wars
without understanding what made the original trilogy great.
Instead of crafting a new mythos,
the film borrows from what's come before using the exact same plot points,
archetypes and even sets.
But the end result becomes nothing more than a parody of its predecessors.
For example,
consider how the rise of Skywalker treats raised flirtations with the dark side.
This is the same arc as Luke's and return of the Jedi. But in that film,
Luke truly did grapple with joining his father at one point,
even succumbing to his darker impulses yet in the rise of Skywalker,
this arc is never fully dramatize. Ray has a dark vision,
does a little force lightening,
and that's pretty much it Palpatine tries to tempt Ray into succumbing to her
darker impulses just as he attempted Luke,
but Ray barely flinches from her morals. It's all talk.
The Ark exists simply for the sake of repetition. It's just, as Mark said,
history repeats itself first as a tragedy. And then, well as this,
even the rise of Skywalker's twists are lifted from the original trilogy.
The Ray Palpatine granddaughter reveal is basically just a water down,
but the Palpatine reveal lacks any of the dramatic weight of its predecessor in
the original trilogy.
Luke believed his father was a Jedi hero who was betrayed and murdered by
Darren.
A young Jedi named DaVita who was a pupil of mine until he turned to
evil, helped the empire hunt down and destroy the Jedi Knights.
He betrayed and murdered Joe father.
When the big Vader turn happens, it shatters everything.
Luke believed to be true. It undermined the foundation of his moral compass.
His father wasn't a hero,
but the villain who betrayed the Jedi and killed his surrogate father.
Now let's look at Ray.
Ray thinks her parents were junk traders who abandoned her.
So the reveal that Palpatine is her grandfather doesn't hold the same emotional
weight. It's not like she wanted to be a great Jedi to emulate her dead parents.
Also,
Ray hasn't even met Palpatine yet and knows nothing about him other than he's a
bad guy. And once she finds out Palpatine is her grandfather not much changes.
He's still just a guy that needs to be defeated.
Her world hasn't been shattered in the same way that Luke's was. If anything,
the Palpatine twist is more of a revelation for fans as they recount all the
great prequel memes they've seen rise of Skywalker is filled with these moments
like Louie dressing up like his uncle,
the film incessantly dresses itself up like the originals repeating word for
word shot per what happened to them.
But without any of the contexts that made these moments work,
these moments only exist as hollow callbacks,
any emotional or dramatic heft is entirely dependent on the viewer's
relationship to the original trilogy. Just look at how rise of Skywalker,
butchers, Han Solo's most famous line.
Yeah,
I know this.
Hearkens back to one of the most famous moments in empire strikes back. I love.
That.
Simple exchange was the culmination of Han and Leia's tumultuous. Will they?
Or won't they romantic relationship?
The reason the line has become a touchstone for the characters and the series as
a whole is because of the buildup beforehand,
the original films put in the work with their relationship to make this single
line iconic. But in the rise of Skywalker,
the lines just reused as a reference for fans.
It doesn't have any narrative value in the film,
except as a way to remind viewers of a movie,
they feel nostalgic for rise of Skywalker is built on references,
but it doesn't take into account.
The hundreds of moments beforehand that may these iconic moments work,
the relationships, the characters,
the world building that were the foundation to the original series success.
And without this footing, these references are just that hollow and empty.
A farce of the original trilogy rise of Skywalker becomes so obsessed with
hearkening back that it even sacrifices, logic and its own characters,
motivations at the behest of these callbacks. For one,
how the heck is Palpatine even alive?
Why bring him back as the villain in the first place? Well,
let's take it from JJ Abrams. The more we talked about.
The more inevitable it felt that this character who was so important in the
first two trilogies, uh, come back and, and in some form.
That's the truth. In a nutshell, Palpatine is the bill.
And only because he's the bill and from the first six films,
it doesn't make any sense that the emperor has somehow survived being thrown
down a reactor shaft and blown to smithereens in return of the Jedi rise of
Skywalker doesn't care. Somehow Palpatine returns.
[Inaudible].
Without any clear logical reason for Palpatine's return.
The character feels like a farce of who he wants was even palpate King's
motivations. Now don't make a lick of sense.
He sends Kylo to kill Ray yet when Ray shows up and confronts him at the end of
the film, Palpatine changes his tune completely, right?
I never wanted you dead. I wanted you here.
This yet again is a direct callback to the original trilogy or Palpatine tried
to convert Luke to the dark side.
Looking forward to completing your trip in time.
You will call me last time.
Thus, the only reason why Palpatine's motivation rise of Skywalker changes is to
mirror his motivation in return of the Jedi and rise of Skywalker is litter.
These inconsistencies,
how does Palpatine suddenly a massive fleet of ships all equipped with planet
destroying weapons?
Doesn't really matter because rise of Skywalker has to end with an aerial space,
just like return of the Jedi.
The rise of Skywalker attempts to elevate itself to the Heights of the original
films by playing on their success structure and nostalgia.
But instead the film becomes nothing more than a sad copy of a copy.
It's so obsessed with hearkening backwards,
that it never creates an identity of its own history has now become star Wars
own undoing. Well, what do you guys think?
Are we being too hard on the ninth star Wars film,
or is it really just a bargain bin version of the return of the Jedi?
Let us know what you think in the comments below,
please don't yell at us and a big thanks to all our patrons for supporting our
podcasts and the channel execute order 66 on that subscribe button.
And as always, thanks for watching guys. Peace.
[Inaudible].